red we're glad you're here thank you a
flurry of activity coming out of
Washington DC Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell putting together a plan
to avert a government shutdown after
Democrats refused to budge on funding a
border wall also president Trump's
scoring a big win after the Senate
overwhelmingly passes a criminal justice
reform bill he's ready to sign it into
office into law once he moves through
the house and president Trump declaring
victory internationally here against
Isis in Syria in a tweet in announcing
the 2,000 American troops will be
withdrawing very soon all of this course
happening as Democrats prepare an
onslaught of investigations into
President Trump and his administration
Dana I'll start with you this feels like
a a muddy moment at the end of the year
get everything done today very much so
you've got this transition of power
you've got the president saying he wants
a wall he's gonna shut it down if he
doesn't get it now we're seeing a CR
into dist ended February when Nancy
Pelosi you'll be the Speaker of the
House yeah prison reform bill passes but
overwhelmingly bipartisan and then this
declaration that hey we've defeated Isis
time to leave Syria a lot of questions
about where that came from and how
quickly that'll happen what do you make
of well take em one by one if I could
because I think there's some logic to
that to them I prefer that you don't
need to it all at once okay on the wall
funding I think that this is just a nod
to reality it was going to be very
difficult to do this without having a
shutdown of the government I think the
president didn't want that distraction
over the next two weeks it wasn't gonna
be possible to get the five billion and
I think that they just realized that
we're going to have to have this fight
another time and it is just reality that
the why do you want to have it when the
Democrats are in charge but just because
they were gonna be able to do it now so
it's almost like if he gave the
direction to the agency he's like let me
know what money you have available we
might be able to reprogram it of course
the Congress is saying maybe you can't
do that but it's sort of it's like you
can argue it round or argument flat
because the Democrats are not saying
they are not for any border security
they they would be for border security
they just don't want him to call it the
wall yeah Wyatt wife
semantics and fence moral but a wall is
there is that and then on criminal
justice reform this is a big win for him
and sometimes Republican presidents can
get things done that Democrats can't
this is a bill that was stalled during
the Obama administration it could not
get through the Republican Senate but
President Trump put his shoulder behind
it so did Jared Kushner but also give a
hand to the Democrats who said we want
to work with him it's that important
sometimes issues take so long to work
its way through and the public has to
come along takes a little while to do
that this is a big win and it will help
a lot of people so that's good on Isis I
think that one is it's certainly the
president's prerogative it just seemed
curious I think we'll probably hear a
lot more about it and I hope he's right
but yeah I mean I think we all if Isis
has been decimated but if you were not
there Iran still is Turkey still is
Russia and so then all of your other
priorities get a little bit washed up
don't you think it's interesting though
that so much he's pulling out this
libertarian muscle all of a sudden with
the criminal justice reform everyone was
saying oh that you know that reflects
that the libertarian wing of the
Republican Party is strong also when you
talk about Syria withdrawing the troops
I think it was it was a different side
of him and it was a side that he
campaigned heavily on I remember when he
was campaigning think hearing him talk
about you know his involvement in
potential war or that was something I
have a strong libertarian streak that
kind of attracted me to him and I wonder
if that part of the party the Rand
Paul's the Mike Lee's have put a little
bit of pressure on him to not go so
hawkish and to try to get some of these
things done that they feel will appeal
more to not only them but also to
independent voters to people in the
center to younger voters as he looks
forward to you know his next run he's
going to need a lot of those people in
the middle who might be attracted to
policies like you know if there it is it
will be a nice thing for him PD him to
be able to say in 2020 hey we passed a
criminal justice reform
I'm the president for everybody the
Forgotten men and women in prison too
who had sentences that didn't fit the
crime is this a win is this the win for
the president on that issue yeah it's
interesting to me because from what we
hear to air kushner has been the guy
who's putting himself out there I think
a lot of people feel as if they've been
talking and just stumped by the presence
of Jeff Sessions as Attorney General who
refused to move on is then Mitch
McConnell
who wouldn't call a boat Mitch McConnell
changed his mind and went along and but
the president the White House have been
in favor of this all along and so yes in
that sense you could say it's a win for
the president do you feel like Democrats
are they finding a groove we talked
about these investigations is that gonna
be what they're sort of known for in
2019 if you look forward into the new
year are they gonna are they gonna focus
on any legislation or it will I mean
we're the list of investigations tax
Trump's tax returns tax organization his
business interests Ryan's in key members
of his cabinet you know Elijah come and
sent 51 letters to the White House
recently demanding that by middle of
January there's answers on all this
stuff what will define Democrats in the
new year well I think for Democrats that
will be all about trying to get
something done but I think this will be
a part of it because so much of
everything we talk about Pete is
President Trump and right now his
troubles are mounting in the closing of
his foundation here so much of it is
just everything Trump is news but in
fact I think what you're going to see
especially from Nancy Pelosi in house
leadership is an emphasis on showing
voters that guess what our our party is
able to succeed and to reach solutions
get things done for you like for
instance when we talk about this wall I
mean President Trump said oh you know
what Mexico is going to pay for it
that's what you can't paint it right
then he said oh the military will build
it right and then he said I don't know
I'll find the money we're gonna get and
obviously it was never gonna get done
was an obvious but I mean I think
there's winning I think you're pointing
out some fair moments where that has
been hedged upon it and I will say this
to you on Syria I am stunned it looks to
me like we have flipped identities the
Republicans are the ones Lindsey Graham
and others saying this is a huge Obama
like mistake and then you go and you
listen to the list are consistent
consistent on this issue but then you
hear people I'm looking to hear ted Lieu
the congressman from California Robert
Ford who was Obama's first ambassador to
Syria saying US has no national interest
but I think it's obvious that the
Iranians and the Russians continue to
prop up Bashar al Assad and we remember
Trump going after the redline and all
that and we still have troops in
Afghanistan and elsewhere I don't
understand what he's doing no this is
remember during the campaign he ran on
we've been nation-building in Middle
East for too long it's time to come home
this is an extension of that the
question is who fills that vacuum and
Greg I want to go to you the ah thank
you yes you're right I was ready to go
get a glass of water Dana said the wall
is it a nod to reality or is that a
compromise did he or did he give in to
Nancy Pelosi are they winning on this I
don't know too soon to tell
I I want to I want to take all of these
issues separately okay
number one no I'm going to put them up
dammit I'm gonna put number one we all
think this is big news because the
really big news isn't happening which
means the country's in pretty good
condition we have low crime we have a
lot of optimism so now we have all these
little things and the reason why it's
all about Trump is because the media
makes it all about Trump this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy if there was no
Trump god help us all right what would
we be talking about anyway prison reform
okay I kind of get the sense that this
is the Miss Congeniality award right
this is like Oh finally something good I
have mixed feelings about this I look
and I think we're into our fourth decade
of decline in violent crime this is the
safest society known to mankind do you
necessarily necessarily reform something
that is this successful having said that
I read the reforms I think they're
fairly moderate I don't see anything
it's it's affecting 10% the federal
inmates ten percent of the prison
population it's focusing on a portion of
that there's like twenty five hundred
other prisoners that can apply for some
kind of early release so it's actually
fairly small steps the key is the
training right to get these to get
inmates to learn something so that when
they get out of prison they don't end up
back in prison and I think that's an
important piece to this and and that's
the positive part about this but my
overall observation on this is you got
criminal justice reform you got actual
gun control he banned bumped bump stocks
we're pulling out of Syria the deficits
keeps growing I'm pretty sure we have a
progressive in office I mean he said
this three years ago Trump is a centrist
he's a pragmatist you can't guess which
way he's gonna go he's not an ideologue
in it it's it's weird to see the
Democrats back to the wall mm-hmm it's
weird to see the Democrats not
cooperating with this guy
did prison reform right when he's
pulling out of Syria he wants the wall
what will he give you he will give you
what you want so it's clearly about
being an obstructionist that's the
democrats the democrats are you kidding
after obama you now are gonna say that
it's the Democrats who are obstruction
he proves that he is willing to reach
across the aisle insurance might be part
of it Jim if you listened to him
campaigning back in the day this is the
stuff he was saying everybody wants to
paint him as an extremist because when
it comes to the issue of immigration
he's really hard on the wall and then
securing the border but on other issues
he will find that he was going to the
deficit this has rocketed the house
freedom caucus will be on the floor
tonight saying Boston Oh Daniel on the
wall here is a bad deal for the
president Trump is flipping people in
their beliefs for so you have Democrats
complaining about the deficit and
Republicans complaining about whatever
presidents empower the out party yeah I
just think that you know the old news is
you run you run to the right govern in
the middle Clinton ran to the left and
he governed in the middle that's what's
happening
Wilson you will see I but the cirrie
one's a big one keep your eyes on that
he's that's gonna be on it just may be
that he doesn't want he doesn't he was
like this with Iraq he is stingy about
American bloodshed yeah well and for
good reason yeah how long everything are
Afghanistan Oh